That was you, Hédi Fried, welcome.
Thank you.
You have ...
You have spoken ...
... with and to you people for 30 years.
Yes.
... about holocaust.
Have ...
And you've now collected their most common, and the most important, questions from them in a book.
Yes.
In these 30 years, have you noticed any change in their engagement, in any way?
In general, society's engagement has ...
... become greater.
In the beginning, people didn't even want to listen to what had happened.
And one has to make people understand ...
... that things can happen.
Impossible things happen.
We didn't even think that things would happen.
When we saw a clip of him screaming ...
... my mom said that he was just a crazy person ...
... in Germany. And Germany is so far away, so don't worry.
Yes, do you remember hearing him on the radio?
Yes.
You lived in Romania at that time.
So is that your first memory of Hitler, hearing him on the radio?
Yes.
And you were living peacefully and untouched by ...
We lived in a small town, that consisted of ...
... 30.000 inhabitants.
And different kinds of minorities.
And seemingly people were living ...
... side by side.
But ...
Antisemitism existed.
But you ...
You hear Hitler on the radio and then ...
... time passes, and things develop ...
... when you look back, quite fast.
Yes.
But still, it's like ...
A day passes at a time, and suddenly you're living in a ghetto.
And then one day, you and your sister, your mother and your father find yourself sitting on a train to Auschwitz.
Yes.
It's difficult to understand ...
When one knows what happened ...
... it's difficult to understand how that could happen.
It is difficult to understand.
But people are constructed in a way ...
... that as long as ...
... life isn't at risk ...
... you continue.
It worsens.
It's not good.
But ...
You can live with it.
It might pass.
I usually say that ...
An injustice is like a grain of sand in your hand ...
You can't feel the weight of it.
But injustices have the tendency to ...
... multiply themselves.
And they become more and more and more.
And in the end, you can't bear them.
That's why it's important to act while there's still time.
And if one compares then to the present ...
... there are so many similarities ...
... that people should think again both once and twice.
You arrived in Auschwitz with your mother, father and sister ...
... what is your first memory from disembarking the train there?
Powerful floodlights that blind us.
A smell that penetrates your body and soul. You don't know what it is.
Mom is crying «they're going to kill us».
«No, this is just the factories where we're going to work», I say to comfort her.
A German with a baton ...
... is standing there ...
... deciding the fate ...
... of those who have arrived.
He points at my mother.
«To the right.»
My sister and I, «to the left».
«Those are my children», my mother says.
«We want to stay together!»
«You'll meet them later, you're traveling with a truck and they can walk.»
Water. We didn't get water for three days.
«You'll get coffee when you get there.»
When they got there ...
... they turned on the gas taps.
Those are my first memories.
And the German you met there, you've later learned that that was Dr. Mengele.
Yes.
Who was one of the worst, we could say.
How did you experience the solidarity between the prisoners, you you trust the others?
... Or was it just your sister that you felt you could ..?
It was my sister and ...
... our group of friends. Those of us who had come from the same town.
There was small cliques.
And the solidarity there wasn't greater ...
... than ...
... it is in the world in general.
People weren't better ...
They weren't worse.
They were exactly like ...
... they are in the world today.
Everywhere.
You sister, who is still alive ...
... and whom you talk with every day ...
... how significant was she to you in Auschwitz?
If we hadn't been together, we might not have survived.
Because if one of us felt completely defeated ...
... the other could ...
... pep her up.
And the other way around.
So we tried to ...
... help each other endure this.
When you throughout these years ...
... have spoken to young people and told the story ...
What has been the hardest thing for you to tell and to relive?
The hardest ... Everything is hard.
Every time I tell the story, I'm back there.
And every time, there is a process.
Because this is impossible to forget.
But you can learn to live with it.
And to achieve that ...
... you need to ...
... process it again and again and again.
Are there things ...
... when you're telling this story, that you ...
... don't tell?
That are too difficult to talk about?
There is nothing I don't talk about.
And there are no questions I won't answer.
When I'm out in the schools, I usually tell them to ask questions ...
And ..
The questions are more important than the answers.
And ...
There are no ...
... questions that are forbidden.
I want them to be able to ask any questions.
You were ...
You were in another camp when you were freed.
Yes. I was at Auschwitz first.
And from there I went to ...
... three different work camps.
And from there, in the last stage of the war ...
... to Bergen-Belsen.
And your sister was still with you?
Yes, she was there.
How were you at that time?
What state were you in?
I became sick in Bergen-Belsen.
First, I was ...
I was infected with lice.
I had managed to stay away from the lice the whole time.
But in Bergen-Belsen, I was infected.
And I was quite sick for a while.
And there, she was the one who helped me back to life. So ...
We have always been there for each other.
And later I got jaundice.
And ...
... later I recovered from that as well.
And later the Swedish Red Cross came ...
And they were bringing, to Sweden, 10.000 survivors ...
... and sick people from the hospital ...
... and their relatives.
What is your strongest memory from arriving in Sweden?
It's milk chocolate!
When we arrived, the Swedish Women's Voluntary Defence Service were at the dock ...
... and they gave us hot chocolate and sandwiches.
And the drink was divine!
Sweet and hot.
So milk chocolate represents Sweden even today.
I just have to say that ...
The memory you talk about ...
And I just have to thank you for letting me listen to your story ...
I consider you a herald.
And when you talk about the grain of sand that doesn't weigh anything, the injustice ...
And when they become more, you can feel the weight ...
What you say in this sentence ...
... is wiser than anything Adolf Hitler managed to do as a screaming demagogue.
And it is a privilege to be able so sit and listen to you.
Your life turned out well, you got married and had three kids ...
You became a psychologist ...
Other survivors have said that they have a ...
... special relationship with food, after having ...
... been so hungry.
Oh yes.
You either have a fully stocked refrigerator ...
... or you have an empty refrigerator.
And mine is empty.
Why is that?
Because I cannot throw food away.
And one person doesn't eat that much.
To buy food and then to let it waste away ...
... that is the worst thing I can imagine.
To throw away a small piece of bread ...
... is impossible.
When it gets moldy, I will look at it and get sad ...
And I don't quite know what to do with it.
It's not easy.
Have you had nightmares?
If I've had nightmares?
Yes.
I've had nightmares.
What ...
What kind of things might appear in your nightmares?
In the beginning, the nightmares were that I was in Sweden ...
... and that I travel back to Romania ...
... and that my children are stuck in Sweden and that I can't meet them.
Because they keep me there.
And ...
And that ...
I didn't want to go back, but I did.
And when I got back home ...
... these nightmares disappeared.
Well, not completely, but they weren't as intensive.
And then when I went back to Auschwitz it was about the same ...
It became easier.
With the background that you have ...
What ...
What does the world look like in your eyes?
Sad.
Like I mentioned, in some way, I see a ...
Déjà vu.
I have a feeling that I'm looking through binoculars ...
... the wrong way.
What I see is small.
The things that I once saw big.
And I wonder ...
... what is it going to become?
Are things going to develop the same way?
That can't happen.
That ...
That is what I try to ...
... say, that there are so many ...
similarities.
And it could happen, maybe not the same way, but when they say that ...
... that ...
... that everything is narration, the postmodernists, for example ...
What do they mean?
That what is true has become a lie?
That Auschwitz never existed?
Is that true?
So the ...
The world has become strange.
But it is still possible to resist.
Because, I might have said this earlier ...
It looks so terrifying, but we cannot be scared.
As I've said, to take the bull by the horns. Fight against it.
And I feel that the young people are with me today!
People ask: «What are we going to do?».
«What kind of possibilities do we have?»
Unfortunately, there are no short term possibilities.
But long term, the solution is education.
We can see how education has already ...
... brought out a youth that ...
... is more active ...
... who are there for each other, who are less egoistical ...
... who have more empathy ...
And ...
... who hopefully have a moral compass.
In this show, we have earlier ...
... talked about faith and doubt.
Yes.
And I know that you still have your faith from your childhood.
And a final question, do you still believe in God?
My ...
Every Jew has his or her own faith.
And my faith hasn't changed. I'm a Jew, and I will stay a Jew.
And ...
And I have never been a believer who takes everything literal.
But the faith that I had, I still have, yes.
Hédi Fried, thank you so much for being here with us tonight.